Peggy 18
hello everyone I welcome to this post
III 2015 special presentation of Metal
Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain back at e3
2015 we showed you an example of how you
can jump into free roam and complete
side ups and then jump into a mission we
also explained how missions can be
completed in a variety of different ways
and today we're going to show you some
of those varieties back at e3 we showed
you how to complete the mission a hero's
way using one type of approach we used
Walker gear back then today we'll try
something different and show you some
variations using a different buddy and
other types of equipment in addition to
other approaches to the same mission so
without further ado let's jump to some
gameplay alright so here we are in our
ACC once again and we have quiet as our
buddy
today we'll jump to the same mission the
hero's way and show a different approach
last time we approached from the north
this time we'll try approaching from the
east and show you a different way that
we can tackle this mission poaching from
the north was farther but it had fewer
enemies coming in from the east is
closer and more direct but it's more
patrolled and has more obstacles which
will make things a little bit more
difficult since this will be more
difficult than before will enlist quiets
help and infiltrate as a two-man
fireteam
this time we want to go non-lethal so as
our primary weapon we'll choose a
non-lethal assault rifle which fires
rubber bullets and will stun enemies
rather than kill them and as our
secondary weapon will use a tranquilizer
pistol for quietly quicker with a
tranquilizer sniper rifle and since
we're dropping into remote location
we'll also take a vehicle with us
and once again we could choose a drop
time here let's just go ahead and choose
ASAP your target is a Spetsnaz
detachment commander your orders are to
take him out
this kills like his it'd be a shame to
waste him and I'll leave the method up
to you boss make your way to - ugh uncle
a and eliminate the target alright so
here we are on the earth spaced about
Afghanistan once again and we're
fast-forwarding things little it's a
good time
and here we are so we can see quiet is
here with us so let's go ahead and call
upon some support
we'll send her up ahead scout out the
area and mark targets for us as you can
see allies are marked by the green
Diamond Dogs logo as well as your own
vehicles and we'll go ahead jump to our
vehicle and rendezvous with her at our
destination you've arrived at the
objective you're Chuck Justice Vinson US
recon detail winners give your guard up
alright so we've arrived at our marker
and as you can see enemies have been
marked by the red triangles on the
screen thanks to quiet so she's finished
scouting now and should be taking up a
snake position can also see here that
quiet has prepared some supplies for us
so if we need to resupply and get ammo
we can head back here
the map has been updated alright and we
have a sniper so let's have quite take
care of this guy higher
[Music]
and now we should be able to get close
sit on him all right we have a two-man
cell up ahead
so we'll cordon eight with quiet to take
these guys out without raising an alarm
and move on head
you gonna extract him this looks like
the meeting of the Spetsnaz true says we
saw into you three video you need to get
closer to identify the target analysis
looky there that's the target
alright so there's our target that said
he's guarded by a bunch of soldiers and
we would raise an alarm if we took only
one of them out even with quiets help so
let's go ahead and try something
different
look up a sleep grenade and have quiet
shoot this fire into the group by doing
so with the goal of mouth without
raising the alarm
boss I gotta say it would be a waste to
kill him by putting him to sleep doesn't
count as eliminating him either dis
knocking him out alright now we need to
recover our target but first to plan for
our escape
we'll have quiet move to another cycling
point and provide cover
haven't Fulton these guys out what leave
no evidence behind now we need to do is
vacate the area tell me quietly so date
are you to a place outside Bosch
ejectives Paisley exfiltrate out of the
hot zone by chopper or on land an enemy
noticed us
unfortunately this guy has a helmet on
we'll have quite helped us out once
again by shooting off the helmet giving
us a clean shot
now as we drive out of here your market
or landing zone and have quiet provide
cover fire as we make our way there as
you can see she'll provide cover fire
limiting enemies in our path
extraction
and in this case we have a vehicle
several enemies in it while it did
manage tranquilized one of them however
the others in the vehicle are still
coming after us and have now opened fire
let's change our route and head to the
landing zone so we can vacate the
mission area
one
tell me
look out here provide some comfort for
quiet she needs it
coast is clear let's go ahead and get on
the chopper and leave the mission area
I get III we showed you how you can use
D dog and you Walker to complete
missions today we showed you how you can
complete the same mission using quiet in
a completely different way this is an
example of how the game is completely
free and open and how you can use your
buddies to completely change the
approach to each mission based on your
personal playstyle and situation so feel
free to mix and match buddies and
equipment as you see fit and poach the
mission in a way that makes the most
sense to you
alright next I'd like to show you
another variation of the same mission a
hero's way previously we approach this
mission from a distance using stealth to
our advantage this time we're going to
go and loud via the air and choose a
landing zone very close to our mission
area as you can see here the landing
zone is red which indicates high risk
which means we have a good chance of
being attacked during our approach thus
we're not being stealthy at all so we're
going to go in loud with guns blazing
which means we'll have to choose some
different equipment this time
so for equipment we will go ahead and
choose the combination of a shotgun and
a machine gun which is used for battle
and close situations such as this and
for our uniform we'll choose a battle
dress which should afford us some
protection since we'll be going into a
heavy fire
and once again we could choose a drop
time here let's just go ahead and choose
ASAP
deploy
your target is a Spetsnaz detachment
commander your orders are to take him
out this skills like his so here we are
at our area of operations and as you can
see we've chosen to come here at night
tonight will provide us some advantage
keep you cover and also enemies will
have their guards lowered which means
that reinforcements will take longer to
arrive
our first step will be to scope the area
out using our in scope and mark targets
you've arrived at the objective your
target should be somewhere that outpost
all right so as we make our approach
will use the helicopters minigun to take
out enemies naturally this will raise an
alarm so we need to eliminate targets as
quickly as possible
likewise we can take advantage of things
such as drum cans create explosions and
general chaos among the enemy alright
get spotted by searchlights let's take
that out as quick as you can and also
let make this guard tower
all right so now we've reached our
destination so we'll go ahead and
disembark
we'll throw a flare grenade so we can
mark our helicopters location and switch
to our machine gun and head on in
there's a smoke grenade provide cover
and then equip night-vision goggles so
that we can see the enemies and
eliminate them as we storm the compound
only to move quickly here note that our
target is not in the first floor where
he was previously
you
ed inserts upstairs again keep in mind
that time is of the essence as
reinforcements will arrive shortly
that's the target
alright so there's our target we will
hit you stun grenades pick them out
ah I gotta say it would be a waste to
killing
and we'll now need to extract them from
the mission area so we'll call the
helicopter back to our landing zone
we could attempt to use a fulton but it
wouldn't be wise since wilkins will
likely get shot down during battle
so we'll carry him and load him on
manually
let's go over their target
no can depart the mission area
and that's mission complete
right this was an example of a surgical
air raid today's mission was to
eliminate a target this tactic is
particularly useful for rescue missions
that said since the enemy will be on
high alert
mission preparation is critical we'll
need to gather Intel study landscape
layout of buildings and target locations
to ensure you can quickly storm the area
and make your escape before the enemy
has a chance to respond but for advanced
players this may be an exciting
challenge to try all right now up to
this point we've showed you various ways
that we can infiltrate enemy territory
approach take out enemies and extract
our target that said when you think
about it this may not necessarily be the
best approach for all people
whenever you infiltrate an enemy outpost
you're exposing yourself to danger so
for those who want to minimize risk
safer and wiser to keep your distance
and approach from afar so this time
we'll show you an example of that and
how to complete the mission from long
range
the mission is the same a hero's way but
as you'll see the impression you get
from the stealth gameplay will be
completely different so first of all
we'll set our landing zone far away from
the outpost which is actually quite near
where we started off our e3 demo and
since we'll be covering a lot of ground
we'll choose D horse as our buddy and
for our weapon we'll choose a sniper
rifle and equip it with a scope that has
eight times magnification so that we can
eliminate the target from far away
now we're set so let's go ahead and
deploy ASAP your target is a Spetsnaz
detachment commander your orders are to
take him out the skills like his it'd be
a shame to waste him but I'll leave the
method up to you us make your way to -
ugga Calais and eliminate the target
airball
all right so here we are at a landing
zone but before I proceed we look around
we see some plants here medicinal herbs
that we can gather so let's go ahead and
pick that up golden Crescent it's a type
of medicinal and we'll be done divorce
that to make tranquilizer rounds more
potent and look for an area or we can
scout out our mission so this dune here
looks like a high point where we can
gather some Intel yeah
yeah
[Applause]
we arrived at our marker let's go ahead
and do some recon analysis complete
this me various soldiers Hank courtyard
for the meeting which means that the
commander should be nearby
it's not on the second floor analysis
complete
looks like that could be our target
faces so we can ID the targets manga
placed seems like you're all gathering
in one spot for the meeting we don't
have a clear shot through the building
here so we'll place a marker and see if
we can find a better location to take
our shot there's our target and there's
a high point here nearby which should
provide us a clear shot manga placed
see you there
that said there are guards take the long
way around and avoid detection
we can throw it to the marker as we
wouldn't want to blow this opportunity
by setting up an alarm and having our
target vacate the area yeah
yeah
yeah you arrived to the objective target
should be somewhere that outpost yeah
don't forget he has a Spetsnaz recon
detail with him keep your guard up yeah
you
all right so we arrived at our snipe
point roughly on the opposite end of the
outpost from our previous location
there's a guard tower here on the
southern end
you're still continuing to have the
meeting let's just wait here till we can
get a clear shot our target
timing will be critical here
you see one man heading up the second
floor and this is our target that's the
target
someone said shortly
keep in mind when shooting from long
range it will take some time for your
bullet to reach its target
therefore it's best to wait until your
target is stationary to ensure the best
shot if you try to shoot at targets
while they're on the move you'll not
only have to account for your bullet
drop and the time it takes for your
blood to reach the target but also
they're moving which is a very highly
difficult shot to make and is
recommended only for the most skilled of
players
if we wanted to we could wait here for
the perfect timing to present itself but
we'll leave that to players to
experiment with in the actual game
instead I'd like to show you some new
equipment and new functionality included
in your bionic arm and using the bionic
arm sonar detector we've located an
enemy nearby we'll take him out
and want to show you one other new
feature which we call the blast start
all right what you saw there was using
rocket propulsion in our blast arm to
quickly incapacitate an opponent
subject on board one of the cool thing
you can do with the blast arm is you can
also fire it off in rocket mode and then
operate it like a remote-controlled
missile
using this we can navigate through the
landscape and find our target
all right yeah
took care of our target already
eliminated so my chopper
mission complete we'll make our way back
to D horse and vacate the hot zone no
your solid series is an action game
series as you all know however in the
phantom pain it is possible to clear
missions by employing strategies to
completely avoid confrontation
altogether if you prefer and show you an
example of that next
[Music]
yeah
yeah
this time we're starting in free roam
mode with a horse and a sneaking suit
for snake mission accepted an app has
been updated
[Music]
so let's begin by downloading our
mission Intel from the mission start
point to the southeast of the mission
area yeah
[Applause]
your target is a Spetsnaz detachment
commander right so scouting out the area
we see here a road trolled by Soviets
leading to our outpost and this vehicle
is carrying Soviet soldiers who are
enroute to the meetings with the
Spetsnaz commander so let's see if we
can intercept this all right so this
time we'll show you some new features of
the cardboard box as you can see the
copper box is equipped with some new
abilities such as the ability to slide
down hills and if you're up on a slope
this may be the fastest way to get from
point A to point B all right so now
we've made it to the road and we'll
leave the cardboard box here in the
middle it looks like the enemy has
noticed it so we'll leave it there to
cause a distraction while we sleep away
we'll use these rocks for cover as we
make our way around the enemy and as you
can see two of the enemy are going to
investigate the cardboard box which will
allow sneak up on the third enemy who is
left to guard the vehicle carefully
approach from behind with some c4
quickly plant it without him noticing
and take cover
we haven't been noticed as long as we
don't move we should be fine
[Applause]
all right so the soldiers have gotten
back into their vehicle and heading off
their meeting without noticing the
present we placed on their comrade so
let's quickly make our way to our
destination and so you can scope things
out
all right so here we are at our outpost
and you can see those are guard years
complete but as you may have noticed on
the way in there's a crack in the wall
which can use the climb if we take a
look with our night-vision goggles you
can see it more clearly so we can take
advantage of that first let's cause the
distraction and get this guy out of our
way
all right so he heard a noise who'd go
to check that out while he's busy we'll
go ahead and climb on in
as we've shown previously snake can use
cracks and walls to climb so we'll get
on top of this building to get a better
view of our target
so we'll use our in scope to verify the
target target
we're Dooku you stir the pasta rallies
noshing and also verify that our
booby-trapped solder is among them
so now all we have to do is equip the c4
and pull the trigger
nothing personal target dead alright
target eliminated complete like you
would call and still have this guy down
here checking out the noise let's get
rid of them and make our way back to the
horse
[Applause]
yeah take slow changes alright you're
out of the hot zone no enemy forces in
pursuit Michigan all right and we've a
cue to the hot zone mission complete
alright and that's it for today hope you
enjoyed these four other examples of how
you can approach our III mission and
heroes way that said keep in mind that
this was just a small sampling of the
limitless possibilities you have at your
disposal for each and every mission in
the game
we hope that players will have fun
experimenting with various techniques
and sharing war stories with each other
that are uniquely their own and result
by the phantom pain will be released in
just under two months on September 1st
2015 thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]